programming throwdown episode 85 holiday party take it away patrick welcome to the last episode of 2018 wow got a lot of exciting stuff planned for this episode. That's right. Some giveaways, which we'll explain in a minute. And hopefully they'll be fun and exciting. And we're recording this. We always, I guess, technically record it live. Like, Jason and I are both live, I guess.
Programming Throwdown 第85期，节日派对。开始吧，Patrick。欢迎来到2018年的最后一期节目，哇，这期节目我们计划了很多精彩的内容。没错。还有一些赠品，我们稍后会解释。希望这些内容既有趣又令人兴奋。我们正在录制这期节目。我想我们通常在技术上都是直播录制的。就像Jason和我，我想我们都在直播。
But this time, people are listening in on the Discord. And if we get any particularly particularly excited uh people into the discord who want to join us on audio chat we might have that that episode don't know what's going to happen it's uh end of the year 2018 anything can happen that's right anything goes it's wild it's crazy speaking of wild crazy and anything goes uh since we called this episode the holiday party episode i want to talk a minute about uh work holiday parties so uh each year at i guess you know every company i've worked at there's always been a holiday party and i think you know hollywood has made a thing of holiday parties like famously i guess the opening
但这次，大家正在Discord上收听。如果我们Discord里有特别特别兴奋的朋友想加入我们的音频聊天，我们可能会安排那个环节。不知道会发生什么，毕竟是2018年的年底，什么都可能发生。没错，一切皆有可能，这很疯狂，很疯狂。说到疯狂、不可思议和一切皆有可能，既然我们把这期节目称为节日派对特辑，我想花点时间聊聊工作中的节日派对。每年，我想在每家我工作过的公司，总会有个节日派对。我想好莱坞已经把节日派对变成了一种文化，比如著名的开场。
of die hard is a holiday party right i haven't watched it in a long time yeah i think that's true so holiday like like it's a a cultural thing i guess uh but i guess it's particularly interesting i don't know that i've ever seen portrayed the uh computer science holiday party uh so so you know it's typically for for those of you who you kind of haven't experienced it yet the way i've typically experienced it is sometime uh near to thanksgiving but normally after thanksgiving but before christmas uh your company will decide to throw a holiday party it may be for the whole company it might be for just your team or normally it's been more like i've seen at like the department level um so depending on the size of your company
《虎胆龙威》的开场就是一场节日派对，对吧？我已经很久没看了。是的，我想那是真的。所以节日就像是一种文化现象。但我猜特别有趣的是，我不知道我是否见过计算机科学界的节日派对。所以，对于那些还没经历过的人，我通常的经历是，在感恩节附近，通常是感恩节之后但在圣诞节之前，公司会决定举办一场节日派对。可能是全公司的，也可能只是你们团队的，或者通常我看到的是部门级别的，这取决于你们公司的规模。
i've worked mostly at large companies so that's you know several hundred to a thousand ish employee level and um and so that's about the size of the holiday party they have it at some you know conference center or uh you know some museum something it just depends on you know sort of the uh current economic environment the sort of culture of your company various things yeah they actually uh they still do the whole company holiday party where i work and uh it's completely insane it's just so many people it's an unbelievable so this is also an interesting time of year because uh for me the two biggest things that are recurring year after year that are kind of most interesting, aside from the event itself, when it takes place, is one, they typically have people dress up. Typically either like at least business casual, but typically more like you're supposed to often black tie. And so most of the people I work for either own zero or one suit and they haven't worn it until except last year's holiday party
我主要在大公司工作，所以那是几百到一千名员工的规模。这就是他们举办节日派对的规模，在某个会议中心或博物馆之类的，这取决于当前的经济环境、公司文化等等。是的，我工作的地方仍然会举办全公司的节日派对，这简直太疯狂了，人太多了，简直不可思议。所以这也是一年中一个有趣的时刻，因为对我来说，除了活动本身和举办时间外，每年重复出现的最有趣的两件事，第一，他们通常要求人们盛装打扮。通常至少是商务休闲装，但通常更像是要求黑领结正装。所以大多数为我工作的人要么根本没有西装，要么只有一套，而且除了去年的节日派对，他们就没穿过。
yeah exactly so it's a very interesting time from people who normally wear jeans and t-shirts or even shorts and flip-flops to see them actually kind of suit up and go to a party so that's the first interesting bit and you say also you see some people because they're they're not used to this they might be unprepared so for example um the last time they wore dress shoes was at the last holiday party and uh they lost the dress shoes so you'll see this person wearing a tuxedo and flip-flops oh no no i didn't never seen this and it's not to make fun of people like i mean i think you can own it right like some people wear the jingle bells suit right that has like just bells all over and like i think that's cool like that's okay
没错，所以对于那些平时穿牛仔裤、T恤，甚至短裤和人字拖的人来说，看到他们穿上西装去参加派对是一个非常有趣的时刻。这是第一个有趣的细节。你说你也会看到一些人，因为他们不习惯这样，所以可能准备不足。例如，他们上次穿正装皮鞋还是在上次节日派对上，结果他们把皮鞋弄丢了，所以你会看到有人穿着燕尾服却踩着人字拖。哦不，我从没见过这个。这并不是要取笑别人，我觉得你可以接受它，比如有些人穿那种叮当响的铃铛西装，上面全是铃铛，我觉得那很酷，那没关系。
because it's kind of a weird thing to ask these people who are not known for wearing sort of nice when i say nice clothes fancy clothes uh to put on fancy clothes and go to this event so it's already a little awkward like everybody kind of gets it not judging those people if if you you know myself i probably don't pull off a, I would be able to be made fun of in 90% of social light circles for what I wear. And it's fine, you know, the faux pas. So I'm not one to throw rocks. So that's the first interesting bit. The second interesting bit is it's typically a you plus one. So you can bring a friend or a spouse or a significant other, your mom, like I've seen, you know, a variety of rules. But it's really interesting because you know these people from work,
因为要求这些平时不穿漂亮衣服——当我说是漂亮衣服时，是指华丽的衣服——的人穿上华丽的衣服去参加这个活动，确实有点奇怪。所以这已经有点尴尬了，每个人都心知肚明，不会评判那些人。如果是我，我可能穿不出那种效果，我穿的衣服在90%的社交圈里都会被嘲笑。没关系，这就是失礼。所以我不是那种会扔石头的人。这是第一个有趣的细节。第二个有趣的细节是，这通常是“你加一”的活动。所以你可以带一个朋友、配偶、另一半，或者你的妈妈，我见过各种各样的规则。但这真的很有趣，因为你认识这些人是在工作中。
but now you're meeting some other person sort of in their life. And most of the time that tends to be someone who's not in computer science. So you get a room that's split kind of, in my opinion, typically almost right down the middle. About 50% sort of engineers and about about 50 kind of non-engineers in a sort of awkward miasma of people in suits and cocktail dresses and ball gowns uh all in an event that probably has some amount of alcohol probably has dancing and music and eating and it's just this uh very interesting time of year did did they change the the alcohol rules
但现在你正在见他们生活中的另一个人。大多数情况下，那个人往往不是从事计算机科学的。所以你会发现房间里的人分成了两半，在我看来，通常几乎是对半开。大约50%是工程师，另外50%是非工程师，在一片穿着西装、鸡尾酒裙和礼服的人群中，在某种尴尬的氛围里，活动通常伴随着一定量的酒精，还有跳舞、音乐和食物，这真是一年中非常有趣的时刻。他们改变酒精供应规则了吗？
this year uh i think there was i forget what the exact rules are those things like two you got two tickets so you could have two drinks okay yeah so they did so actually uh i was one of the companies that didn't do that so i don't i don't really drink i mean it's not a i don't have a any moral issue it's just one of these things that as I've gotten older, it's like the hangover is getting a lot bigger. And so I just stopped drinking at one point. But yeah, they had just totally open bar. And that's actually starting to go the way of the dodo.
今年，我想，我忘了具体的规则是什么了，好像是两张券，所以你可以喝两杯。好吧，是的，他们确实这么做了。实际上，我所在的公司没有这样做。我其实不怎么喝酒，并不是说我有什么道德问题，只是随着年龄增长，宿醉的感觉越来越严重。所以我后来就戒酒了。但他们确实有完全开放的酒吧。这实际上正开始成为过去式。
I know fewer and fewer companies are still doing that um and probably for good measure i mean someone could get just just completely hammered but uh yeah um but yeah that was it's an interesting thing that you know okay you bring um you know somebody either a significant other or a friend or something like that the odds that they're in tech is you know is i don't know what it is but it's not necessarily high in the scheme of all things you can do right and so what happens is you meet other you know pairs of people and and you have maybe a connection with this person that goes like you spent 2 000 hours with this person in the past year and so
我知道越来越少的公司还在这样做，可能也是为了保险起见，毕竟有人可能会喝得烂醉。但那确实是一件有趣的事情，你知道，你带上某人，无论是另一半还是朋友之类的，他们从事科技行业的几率，我不知道是多少，但在所有可能性中并不一定很高。所以发生的情况是，你会遇到其他成对的人，你可能和这个人有某种联系，比如你在过去一年里和这个人相处了2000个小时，所以
you have all these things you want to say in a social setting. Um, and then these other two people have to kind of hit it off right away. And it's just, yeah, in general, it's, it's pretty difficult. It's like, it's a, it's a, it's a little bit of a taxing time to like, make sure, you know, everyone's, everyone's happy and things like that. I generally enjoy it. I'm not the most introverted person, so I tend to have a good time. I also don't drink. And so I do see from my perspective there that seeing people get very sloppy is kind of off-putting. So I'm actually pleasantly surprised
你在社交场合有很多话想说。然后另外两个人必须得立刻合得来。这通常确实相当困难。这有点费劲，要确保每个人都开心之类的。我通常很享受。我不是最内向的人，所以我往往玩得很开心。我也不喝酒。所以从我的角度来看，看到人们喝得烂醉如泥有点让人反感。所以我实际上感到惊喜。
when there's a limit on it, just because it's a different... When you get mismatches there, I think it leads to awkward situations. Yeah, that's the thing. If someone is really hammered, get mismatches there i think it leads to awkward situations um yeah that's the thing if if someone is is really hammered they can kind of cause like irreparable damage you know i mean i mean i have a crazy story where um i actually wasn't there so so there was a um i actually worked in tech when i
当有限制的时候，因为这是不同的……当你出现不匹配时，我认为这会导致尴尬的情况。是的，就是这样。如果有人真的喝醉了，他们可能会造成不可挽回的伤害。我有一个疯狂的故事，我当时其实不在场。我在17岁时就在科技行业工作了。当时有一个节日派对。我其实不记得了，要么是我不能去，要么是我没被邀请，因为那是开放式酒吧。但不管什么原因我没去。后来我听说那个人喝得烂醉，抢过麦克风。这不像那种有乐队表演，然后有人从乐队手里抢走麦克风的情况。没那么戏剧化，但刚好有个麦克风。我想有人刚讲完话，她就走上去，开始说一些关于她同事的非常私人的事情。
was when i was 17 years old. And there was a holiday party. And I actually, I don't remember. I either couldn't go or I wasn't invited because it was an open bar. But there was some reason why I wasn't there. And I heard later that this person got completely smashed and grabbed a microphone. Now, it's not like one of these things where there's a band and this person just steals the microphone from the band. It wasn't that dramatic, but there was just, there happened to be a microphone. I think someone had just finished speaking and she got on the microphone and just started saying, you know, a lot of really personal
事情就是这样。那些伤口，我是说，它们真的不会愈合。不像你的家人，你可以把事情摊开来说，但在我工作的整个期间，那都很尴尬。我是说，好几年都很尴尬。是的，对我来说，我实际上很享受这些活动，因为可以见到人们，见到他们生活中的其他人。
things about her coworkers and things like that. And, and those wounds, I mean, they don't really heal. I mean, it's not like your family where you could kind of just hash it out, but it was awkward the entire duration that I worked there. I mean, for years, it was awkward. Yeah, I mean, for me, I actually enjoy these events as like getting to meet people and getting to meet their other people
就像Jason指出的那样，这很有趣。你和这些人在一起花了很多时间，但很少在社交场合，或者在社交场合的时间非常有限，所以把这两个世界结合在一起很有趣。而且，我结婚了，所以这是我妻子难得能见到我所有同事的机会。所以直到今天，我们今年其实没去，但总的来说，过去几年我们都去了。
that are in their lives. And like Jason pointed out, it's sort of interesting. You spend so much time with these people, but never often in a social setting or in a very reduced amount of time in a social setting and so bring those two worlds together it's kind of interesting and also um you know i'm married and so my wife is like one of the few times she ever gets to meet all the other people i work with and so even to this day so we actually didn't go to the one this year um but in general uh we've gone in years past
她仍然记得她见过的人。比如，“哦，是的，现在我知道了。”如果我提到某人，她会说，“哦，他就是那个穿着什么什么的人。”我会说，“是的，没错。”所以他们听过故事，但这就是他们如何在脑海中固定这些人的形象。所以这实际上是一个愉快的时光。但正如Jason指出的，你不可避免地会从每次节日派对中带回一些故事。是的，这很有道理。如果我能给人们一个建议，那可能就是不要在节日派对上喝得烂醉。这是来自Jason的生活小贴士。是的，祝大家节日快乐。
and she still remembers the people she's met like oh yeah now i know if i say so and so she'll be like oh he was the one wearing or she was the one wearing this stuff and i'm like yes that's right and so like that's how like you know they hear the stories but that's how they fix the people and what they look like in their uh in their head was is meeting them in these scenarios so it's actually a enjoyable time but as jason pointed out you uh inevitably end up with some amount of stories from every holiday party yeah that makes sense if i could give people one bit of advice it would probably be not to get hammered at your holiday party i mean it's just life pro tip from jason yeah i mean mean, happy holidays, everyone.
让我把增益调低一点。但确实，这看起来不是个好主意。如果你很想喝，那么在心里告诉自己，好吧，等我回家，我要买一整瓶酒，和信任的私人朋友开个大派对之类的。但节日派对确实很疯狂，但总的来说，我认为和同事聊天非常有意思。这真的很奇怪，因为你和同事一起吃午饭，所以看起来你
Let me just turn down my gain a little bit. But yeah, it just doesn't seem like a good idea. If you're tempted, then just in your mind, just say, okay, when I go home, I'm going to buy an entire bottle of something and have a huge party with my personal friends who I trust or something like that. But yeah, holiday's yeah. Holiday parties are pretty wild, but in general, I think, um, it's a ton of fun to, to talk to your coworkers. It's really strange because you eat lunch with your coworkers. Um, and so it, it seems like you
应该会建立联系，但在完全社交的场合，同时和亲密朋友及同事在一起，感觉就是不一样。这真的很酷。我玩得很开心。我们每年都很期待。酷。好了，Jason，你为什么不介绍一下今年的赠品计划？
would build, but there's just something about being in a completely social setting and also kind of being around your close friends and your coworkers at the same time. It is really cool. And I have a great time. We look forward to it every year. Cool. All right, Jason, why don't you go over this year's giveaway plans?
来吧。说到期待。你知道，我在Facebook、Twitter和所有其他Patrick还没开通账号的平台上发了帖，我谈到了现在是成为Patreon会员的最后机会等等。然后我设定了截止日期，所以今天早上是Patreon会员的人都在抽奖名单里。然后我花了大约15分钟在Excel里折腾，试图弄清楚如何生成每次操作都不会改变的随机数。我终于搞定了。
Let's do it. Speaking of looking forward to it. So, you know, I posted on Facebook and Twitter and all these other things that Patrick doesn't have accounts for yet and i talked about um how now is the last chance to make a patreon account etc etc and then uh i did the cutoff so uh the patrons who were patreon members on this morning uh were in the raffle um and then what i did is i spent about 15 minutes monkeying around in Excel trying to figure out how to generate random numbers that wouldn't change every time I did anything. I finally got that to work.
我的Excel技能简直烂透了。我不明白为什么我搞不定Excel，那是我的软肋。所以我们有了名单。现在，我们要换个方式。去年我们设定了一个给每个人寄小礼物的任务。我们在国际运输方面遇到了很多问题。事实证明这真的非常非常难。我完全没想到。我原以为这就像打国际电话一样简单。也许我们只需要多付点钱寄到不同的地方。事实证明，在物流上，这简直是一场噩梦。所以这次我们要做的，是我们整年都在谈论
My Excel skills are absolutely terrible. I don't understand how I can't figure out Excel, but that's my Achilles heel. And so we have the names of people. Now, we're going to do a little bit different. You know, last year we set a mission of sending, you know, a little gift to everybody. We ran into a lot of issues with international shipping. It turns out that's really, really hard. I had no idea. I kind of thought that similar to, you know, calling internationally, that it would be easy. Maybe we'd have to pay a little more money to ship to different places. It turns out logistically, it's a total nightmare. And so what we're going to do this time is, you know, we've been spending the whole year talking
节目里的各种书。所以我们想，我们要选15个人，把他们分成五组，每组五人。也就是三组五人。我们会给你选择电子书、我们节目中提到的任何一本书（其实不一定要是今年的，可以是节目中提到的任何书，电子书或实体书），或者你可以选一件T恤。所以这期节目结束后，我会发邮件。这样做的好处是，如果人们还没在Patreon上填地址，我会发邮件给你，到时候你可以告诉我，“是的，我想要一本实体书，这是我的地址”，或者你可以建议要电子书或T恤。
about different books of the show. And so we thought we would do is take 15 people, we'll break them up into five groups of five. So three groups of five. And we'll either give you the option of an e-book, a book from any of our books of the show. It actually doesn't even have to be this year. So it could be any book of the show, an either e-book or physical copy, or you can get a t-shirt um and so what we'll do is after this episode's done i'll send emails out um the nice thing about this too is if people haven't put their address on patreon what i'll do is i'll email you and at that point you could you could either tell me uh yeah i want a physical book and here's my email address or you could give you could suggest the ebook or t-shirt
你不需要地址就能赢，这和去年不同。所以，也许我们先公布前五名。请击鼓。不，我做不到。我没有节奏感。我想我们能不能敲击一下。我们可以敲击麦克风。
and uh and you don't need an address to win, which is different this year. So, yeah. So maybe we'll just go through our first five. Drum roll, please. No, I can't do it. I have no rhythm. I wonder if we could just tap. We could just tap the microphone.
让我试一下。不，不，不。我们要开始了。那行吗？我正在畏缩。Patrick的耳膜都要被震破了。所以我不会读姓氏，以防万一，但姓氏的首字母也许……是的，其实等一下，让我看看能不能把这些都显示在一个屏幕上。哦，戏剧性的停顿，Jason。如果我能把这些都显示在一个屏幕上。人们都像在针尖上一样。
Let me give it a shot. No, no, no. We're going to go. Did that work? I'm wincing. It's like Patrick's eardrums are blown out um so i'm not gonna read last names just in case but um the first initial of the last name maybe yeah actually one sec let me see if i can get this all on one screen here oh the dramatic pause jason if i can get this all on one screen here. Oh, the dramatic pause, Jason. If I can get this all on one screen. People are all like on pins and needles.
针尖上。好了，完美。他们坐在座位边缘，等着呢。我说你的名字和州，怎么样？这大概能缩小范围。或者国家，如果你……其实，好吧。所以来自IA的Jansen是第一名。
Pins and needles. There we go, perfect. On the edge of their seat, we're waiting for it. I'll say your first name and your state. How about that? That probably narrows it down. So, or country, if you, actually, well, yeah. So Jansen fromia is actually number one
他的随机数最高，Jansen，你的随机数是0.994，非常接近1，干得好，先生。第二个是James，我们不知道James来自哪里，James B。然后我们有……所以如果你是James B，我想你得发邮件。我有每个人的邮箱。哦，好的，我能发邮件。我只是不知道Alexander来自哪里。还有来自加拿大的Ian。恭喜你们。这是前五名。你们今晚晚些时候会收到我的邮件。哦，在节目发布前剧透了。没关系，酷。如果他们在Discord里，他们就会知道。是的，我只是在这里做个记录。好的，酷。我会调整节目新闻的顺序，这样你可以处理你的簿记。所以第一个新闻
so he had the highest random number jansen your random number was 0.994 that is very close to one good job sir uh second one is is james uh we don't know where james is from james b um then we have so if you're a james b email i guess you have to email all email i have everyone's email oh okay i'll be able to email i just don't know where Alexander's from. And Ian from Canada. Congratulations. That's our first five. We'll be getting an email from me later on tonight. Oh, spoiler before the episode comes out. That's all right cool well maybe if they're in the discord then uh they'll know yeah i'm just uh just making a note here so okay all right cool well i'll flip around the order of the news of the show so you can do your bookkeeping uh so the first uh news
我们今晚要讨论的是亚马逊的HQ2。这在新闻里出现了很多，或者至少我看到了很多讨论，因为亚马逊在西雅图之外寻找他们的新总部，这引发了关于它将如何运作、税收激励的本质等等的很多讨论和辩论。这很有趣，我想，但我真的不想谈论它，因为政治……谁有时间管那个？好吧，我想你们都应该关心，政治很重要，但不一定是在这个节目上。所以我想谈的是，我注意到，而且我认为自那以后其他几家公司也谈到了寻找和扩张。我想谷歌、苹果和其他公司正在把他们的园区扩展到硅谷之外。亚马逊已经不在硅谷了，而是在西雅图。
article we have for this evening is amazon's hq2 now this was in the news a lot or at least i saw a lot of discussion about it because amazon had a search for their new headquarters outside of seattle and it turned into much uh discussion and debate about how that would work and the nature of tax incentives and all of that and that's interesting i guess but i don't really want to talk about it because yeah politics uh and who has time for that and uh well i guess all of you should politics are important but not necessarily on this show and so uh what i wanted to talk about though is i noticed that and i think several other companies since then have talked about kind of looking and expanding i think google apple others are kind of growing their campuses out of the Silicon Valley area. And Amazon is already not in Silicon Valley, but in Seattle.
我很好奇这是否是一种多元化的趋势，还是人们对已经存在的东西大惊小怪。但出于某种原因，它引起了媒体的注意，至少是公司正在寻求扩展到新的地点，并在传统总部之外发展新的地点，拥有更分散的业务。我相信大多数这些大公司已经在多个地点有业务了。但无论出于什么原因，他们决定强调他们将不仅仅是一个单一地点的身份。我个人希望这是某种趋势的开始。我不知道是不是。我其实了解得不够多，无法对此发表声明。但我希望这是趋势的开始。
And I I'm wondering if this is a trend towards diversification or if it's just people making much ado about what was already there. But for some reason or another, it's caught the attention of media, at least that companies are looking to expand into new locations and grow new locations outside of, I guess, what you would call their traditional headquarters and have a more split presence. I believe most of these big companies already have presence in multiple locations. But for whatever reason, they're deciding to kind of emphasize that they are going to be more than just an identity of a single location. And I, for one, hope this is a beginning of a trend. I don't know that it is. I actually don't know enough to make a statement about that. But I hope that it is the start of a trend
因为我认为人们有更多选择，而不必非得住在西海岸或东海岸、西雅图或华盛顿特区、硅谷或洛杉矶，这真的很好。我认为全国有很多非常棒的地方，而且有很多原因，家庭是一个重要原因，为什么许多人可能不想搬迁。我认为拥有更多选择对行业来说会很棒。是的，我完全同意。我的意思是，我认为……那个未解的问题，而且我认为没人有答案，这就是为什么……好吧，我想没人有答案，这就是为什么它如此悬而未决，那就是软件工程领域在多大程度上遵循帕累托分布。
because I think it really would be good for people to have more choice than having to live in the West Coast or East Coast, Seattle or Washington, D.Cc or the silicon valley or la like i think there's lots of really great places in the country and there's a lot of reasons family being a big one why many people may not want to relocate and having more choices i think would be great for the industry yeah i totally agree i mean i think um the the unanswered question and and i think nobody has this answer which is why um well yeah i guess yeah i would say no one has this answer which is why it's so on the fence is is is how sort of pareto distributed is is the the software
所以你知道，你听说过10倍工程师之类的，对吧？出于某种原因，或者说出于历史原因，纽约、西雅图和湾区有大量非常有才华的软件工程师，对吧？如果你真的需要一支由顶级程序员世界冠军组成的军队之类的，那在其他任何地方都很难得到，对吧？我的意思是，如果你需要三个……我其实去参观过一家公司，我不会说是哪家，但他们不是大公司。我的意思是，也许有几百名工程师，甚至可能只有800名工程师。他们就有两名顶级程序员决赛选手。
engineering field right so you know you hear about the 10x engineer and things like that, right? And so, for whatever reason, or well, for historical reasons, there's a lot of incredibly talented people in New York, Seattle, and the Bay Area, software engineers, right? And if you really need, you know, an army of, you know i don't know top coder world champions or something like that then uh that's hard to get anywhere else right i mean if you need three i actually went to visit a company and they weren't even i'm not going to say who it is but they weren't a big company um i mean maybe on the order of hundreds of engineers, maybe even just 800 engineers. And they had two top coder, like, finalists.
所以，就像前10名的顶级程序员世界冠军。而且，你知道，那家公司甚至没那么大。我的意思是，我们不是在谈论谷歌、苹果或Facebook之类的。所以这在世界其他任何地方都很难做到，对吧？但我认为也许人们开始意识到，A，这并不像人们想象的那么重要，尤其是现在事情正变得越来越商品化。这真的关乎数据科学
So, like, top 10 top coder, you know, world champions. And, you know, the company wasn't even that big. I mean, we're not talking, like, a Google or an Apple or a Facebook or anything like that. And so that's just hard to do anywhere else in the world, right? But I think maybe people are starting to realize that, like, A, that's not as important as people thought, especially as now things are becoming a little bit more of a commodity. And it's really about data science
和理解大量数据之类的，在这些方面，分散开来可能不会有同样的分布。另一个原因是那一代人正在变老，他们可能因为家庭原因之类的，无论如何都会搬走。即使那里有最好的工作，也没关系，他们只是会搬回老家，或者搬到中西部，或者搬到任何地方。所以无论有什么机会，这种人才最终都会扩散，对吧？
and understanding large volumes of data and things like that where spreading it out, there might not be that same distribution. And the other part is that that generation is getting older and they're probably, for family reasons and things like that, moving regardless. It doesn't matter even if there's the best job there, they're just going to move back home or move to the Midwest or move wherever. And so that talent is going to diffuse no matter
在某种程度上。是的。是的。我的意思是，即使在世界其他地方，正如你指出的，欧洲和亚洲也有优秀的人才。我真的希望公司能变得……我不知道，像你说的思想开放。很多地方都有公司，甚至小作坊也遍布各地。但我感觉，你知道，焦点主要集中在那些高薪、有声望的工作上，这是一种说法，它们不仅仅是几个小城市里的零星岗位，往往集中在全球少数几个地方，这使得它们
what opportunities there are, right, to some degree. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, that was a, I mean, I guess even across the rest of the world, as you point out, there are other places in Europe and Asia that have good talent too and i i really hope that companies become i don't know open-minded as you said and there are companies in lots of places like even small shops you know sprinkle all over the place but i feel like you know the focus has largely been the the very high-paying prestigious jobs i guess is one way of saying it uh that aren't just onesies or twosies in a couple small cities, tend to isolate into relatively few places around the globe, which makes them
几乎在定义上就因为很多人去那里而变得生活成本昂贵。我希望它能更分散一点。如果能有额外的选择和更多的机会从人们不一定非要搬迁的地方招聘，那会很好。是的，绝对。而且，这个领域本身还在不断扩大。所以不把全国乃至全世界更多的地方包括进来似乎很傻。这还没谈到远程办公，那是另一个独立的话题。所以，哦，是的，我们会继续讨论。我们应该做的，我想我们已经做过一期关于远程办公的节目了，对吧？如果没有，我们应该在2019年做一期，我们已经排上日程了。好的，我的文章是关于无服务器编程的，这非常有趣。它不是听起来的那样。你知道，当我第一次听到这个时，我以为是BitTorrent点对点，我以为字面意义上的无服务器。它实际的意思是，你基本上不需要维护操作系统。这实际上就是它的意思。所以有AWS Lambda这样的东西。还有一个来自谷歌的旧东西，叫什么来着？
kind of almost by definition expensive to live in because lots of people go there. And I hope it spreads around a little more. It would be nice to have extra choices and more opportunity to recruit from places where people don't necessarily aren't interested in moving yeah yeah absolutely plus i mean the field itself just keeps getting bigger and bigger yeah and so it just seems silly not to include more and more of the country and as you said to the world right and that's not even to talk about remote work which will this whole separate uh thing so oh yeah we'll just keep going we should do it i think we've already done an episode on that right on telecommuting if not about remote work which will this whole separate uh thing so oh yeah we'll just keep going we
像Google Cloud Compute之类的。我不记得名字了。Google Cloud Platform，GCP。那很相似。想法是有一个API。你实现那个API，然后你的程序就不需要操作系统了，对吧？所以，例如，想想操作系统提供了什么，对吧？它给你一个文件系统。它让你访问网络接口之类的东西，这样你就可以和其他计算机通信。然后还有物理设备，如果你在数据中心，你其实不会用到它们。
should do it i think we've already done an episode on that right on telecommuting if not we should do one 2019 we already have it lined up um okay my article was on serverless programming which is is uh really interesting it's not what it sounds you know when i first heard this i kind of thought you know bit torrent peer-to-peer, like I thought literally serverless. What it actually means is basically you don't have to maintain an operating system. That's effectively what it means. So there's this thing called AWS Lambda. There's an old thing from Google called, what was the Google one?
所以只要你能封装它，如果你需要写一些本地文件，你只需为它创建一个API，或者你创建一个FUSE用户空间文件系统之类的。只要你能保证有人能连接到互联网，你就不真的需要维护你自己的操作系统。这样做的好处是，扩展起来容易得多，你不需要启动100个节点，
Like Google Cloud Compute or something. I can't remember the name. Google Cloud Platform, GCP. And that was similar. And the idea is there's an API. You implement that API and then your program doesn't need an operating system, right? So for example, I mean, think about what the operating system provides, right? It gives you a file system. It lets you access things like the network card and things like that so you can, you know, communicate with other computers. And then there's physical things which you're not really going to use
在这些节点上运行你的Docker容器之类的。你只需要这个程序，把它交给亚马逊、谷歌或微软。你说，嘿，我想让这个程序在100台机器上运行。然后如果突然间，你知道，是劳动节，你遇到了巨大的流量，你只需把它增加到200或300。当然，你可以用Docker和其他技术做到这一点，但这让它变得容易得多。所以它开始真正流行起来了。我觉得这很酷。我必须承认，我不是Web开发者，甚至不是Web后端开发者，所以我不能确定，我还没玩过这个，但我很想玩。
if it's in a data center, right? So as long as you can wrap that so you so you could wrap the file system if you need to write some local files you just create an API for that or you create you know a fuse user space file system or something like that as long as you can guarantee that someone can connect to the internet you don't really need to have to be maintaining your own operating system. And the nice thing about that is it's much easier to scale versus you don't have to spin up 100 nodes,
所以我不能确定从技术角度看它是否是个好主意，但仅从产品工程或生产工程的角度来看，它看起来真的很棒。它减少了很多摩擦。我的意思是，当我的程序只是在写日志和与数据库对话时，我真的不需要维护一个文件系统。所以我认为这很酷。这篇文章谈论了它是如何工作的。我想谈谈一个反复出现的主题。那些听我们节目回放的人经常写信给我们，谈论我们过去做出的预测，或者我们过去说过的话。我知道我们谈论很多的一件事是SpaceX、Bigelow Space
run your Docker container on these nodes, things like that. You just have this program and you give it to Amazon or Google or Microsoft. And you say, hey, I want this program to run on 100 machines. And then if all of a sudden, you know, it's Labor Day and you're getting hit with a ton of traffic, you just bump that up to 200 or 300. And of course, you can do that with Docker and this other technology. But but this makes it way, way easier. And so it's starting to really take off i think it's pretty cool i have to admit i i'm not a web developer or even a web backend developer so um i can't say for sure i haven't played around with this yet but i want to
或者维珍银河，对吧？哦，我本可以把那个作为文章的。维珍银河2，或者太空船2。我忘了确切的命名法。但他们最近达到了某些人定义的太空边缘。他们到达了太空。这是理查德·布兰森支持或拥有的公司。我想他确实拥有它。
um so i can't say for sure if it's a good idea from a technical perspective but just from a like product engineering or production engineering perspective, it seems like like really nice. Like it reduces a lot of the friction. I mean, I don't really need to maintain a file system when all my program is doing is writing logs and talking to a database. Right. So I think it's pretty cool. And this article talks all about how that works. I want to talk about a recurring theme people who are listening to the backlog of our episodes often write us in and talk about that we made i knew called predictions i guess but things we've said in the past and i know one of the things we've talked about a lot is spacex bigelow space
他们有一段时间一直试图进入太空，他们想带游客去那里。他们是亚轨道的，所以他们实际上无法像SpaceX那样进入轨道，但他们最近能够到达那里。所以人们有点认为，付费客户——尽管票价极其昂贵——很快就能开始访问太空了。看起来……你知道那要花多少钱吗？我忘了。我想我当时查过，但我现在不看了。好吧，酷。但我选的文章其实是一个免费赠品，那个不收费。SpaceX最近进行了今年的第20次发射，我认为这是一个疯狂的故事，现在有几家公司提供或接近提供
um whether or not i guess virgin galactic is it yeah on these kinds of things oh which i could have made that the article. Virgin Galactic 2, which is the, or Spaceship 2. I forget the exact nomenclature. But they recently reached by what some people define as the edge of space. They reached space. And this is the Richard Branson-backed company or owned company. I guess he owns it anyways.
商业轨道飞行，能够把卫星送上去，希望很快能把人类送回太空。我想现在主要是俄罗斯的火箭能把人送入太空，他们最近出了问题，所以他们遇到了麻烦。所以现在看起来SpaceX和其他公司可能快要成功了。SpaceX今年的第20次发射，看到火箭发射的频率如此之高，这很有趣。也许我以前从没注意过，也许它又变酷了，也许它一直都这么普遍。但我其实认为……我本该试着找一张图表，但我感觉它正变得越来越普遍。我很兴奋，你知道，随着我的孩子们长大，希望他们能看到繁荣的太空。是的，再次进入太空，低价
And they've been for a while trying to get to space uh and they're wanting to take tourists there they're suborbital so they won't actually be able to orbit like a spacex um but they recently were able to get there so people are kind of like thinking might be soon that sort of paying customers albeit very outrageously expensive tickets will actually start being able to kind of visit space it seems like you know how much that would cost i forget i think i looked up at the time i don't look at it okay cool but the article i actually picked that was a bonus freebie no charge for that one uh is spacex recently had their 20th launch of the year and i think this is a crazy story that there are several companies now offering uh or close to offering um commercial
25万美元。好吧，谁会是第一个谈论太空票价摩尔定律之类的人？哦，那是真的。开个玩笑，开个玩笑。我知道那不一样。不过，具体来说，SpaceX的第20次发射很有趣。如果你没在新闻里看到，我鼓励你去看视频。SpaceX在可能的情况下会尝试回收他们的第一级火箭，这样他们就可以回收引擎和所有东西。他们要么降落在驳船上，要么降落在陆地上发射点附近。这次他们正准备降落在陆地上。我猜他们的方法是最初瞄准的不是陆地，而是海里，就在离岸不远的地方。然后一旦它
access to to orbital flights be able to put satellites up and soon hopefully to be able to put humans back uh into space i guess right now it's mostly the the russian uh uh the rockets that are able to put people into space and they recently had a problem and so they've had issues and so now it looks like uh spacex and and other companies might be getting close uh and this uh 20th launch of the year for spacex is it's kind of it's kind of interesting to see how frequently uh rockets are launching and maybe i just never paid attention to it before maybe it's cool again maybe it's always been this common but i actually think uh i should have tried to find a graph of it but i feel like it's becoming more commonplace and i'm excited that you know as my children grow up hopefully they'll be able to you know see uh thriving space yeah for the going to space again low price of
看到一切正常，它会在最后一刻转向降落在着陆垫上。发生的事情是，液压马达中的某个东西出了故障，所以它开始失控旋转。所以他们实际上不再瞄准着陆垫，或者他们没有移动去瞄准着陆垫。直播流实际上切断了，人们假装什么都没发生。但当它回来时，你实际上看了后面的视频，它确实失控旋转了，但他们设法重新获得了控制，这太疯狂了，因为他们没有多少时间去做。算法设法重新获得了对
250 000 okay well do we space who's gonna be the first person to say something about like the moore's law of ticket prices to space or something oh that's true yeah just kidding just kidding i know it's not the same um specifically though this 20th launch of spacex was an interesting one if you if you hadn't seen it in the news i encourage you to watch the video of it so spacex when possible tries to re-land their first stage so they can recover the engines and everything and they either landed on a barge or back near the uh where they launched from on land and this one they were headed back to land on the land and i guess the uh approach has it to be targeting sort of not on the land initially but on on the sea like just offshore in the ocean and then once it sort of
火箭的控制，他们实际上有效地把它降落在海里，在非常浅的水域。他们在最后一秒降落了。它几乎是在悬停。但当然，当它准备降落时，下面没有坚固的东西，所以它就倾斜掉进了海里。但对于本可能是一次非常灾难性的失败来说，
sees everything's a-okay it sort of at the last minute kind of pivots over to land on the the landing pad and what happened was it's sort of something in one of the hydraulic motors uh malfunction and so it begins to spin out of control uh and so they actually you know no longer are targeting the the landing pad or they don't move to target the landing pad and the live stream actually cuts away and the people pretend like nothing's happening but then when it comes back and you actually watch the video later uh it sort of spins out of control but they managed to actually regain control which is crazy because they don't have a lot of time to do it they manage the algorithms managed to regain control of the
它变成了一次几乎平淡无奇的事情。我想他们最终回收了火箭，我想他们决定只能把它拆了当零件，或者无论如何，在盐水里泡过之后他们将无法重复使用它。这说得通，但它已经这么久没有出现任何问题，以至于它几乎变得司空见惯，这真是太疯狂了。人们……我记得在这个播客上，和人们谈论过，就像“哦，这太荒谬了，你会飞上去，然后把火箭的一部分飞回来，涉及的能量和燃料量，你必须使用，而且没有
rocket and they actually effectively land it on the ocean, like in a very shallow water. They kind of land it at the last second. It's like barely hovering. But then, of course, when it goes to land, there's no solid thing there, and so it just sort of tips into the ocean. But for what could have been a very catastrophic failure,
办法，这说不通。”而现在就像，“哦，是的，当然他们会那样做。”是的，这令人难以置信。是的，所以我想这就是进步的本质。是的，我想也许人工智能能够以如此高的效率控制那枚火箭，以至于它值得挽救之类的。我的节目主题或我的第二个新闻是Flutter，Flutter 1.0。所以Flutter非常有趣。我听过关于它的褒贬不一的评价，但基本上Flutter是什么……我不知道我们是否谈论过ReactJS，或者抱歉，React Native。是的，好的。哦，对了。
it turns into an almost uneventful thing. And I think they ended up recovering the rocket, and I think they decided they're going to have to just scrap it for parts or whatever they won't be able to reuse it after being in the salt water um that makes sense but it's just it's kind of crazy that it had gone so long without any issues that it's almost become commonplace this thing that people you know i kind of remember on this podcast and having talked to people it's been like oh this is ridiculous that you would fly up and fly part of the rocket back just the amounts of energy involved and fuel you'd have to use and there's no
我们在谈论Clojure和Clojure Script时谈论过所有这些。所以简单回顾一下，React Native是你用HTML和JavaScript的混合体编写代码。但它实际上不是HTML。它是XML，我们这么说吧，还有JavaScript。然后发生的事情是，React Native最终基本上让那段代码驱动了一堆原生组件。所以，例如，如果你有一个XML标签button，那么它会在屏幕上画一个按钮。那个标签接受像text之类的属性。那个标签可以有子标签，用于各种不同的选择之类的。所以底层发生的事情是，那个按钮，XML标签，
way that doesn't make sense and now it's just like oh yeah of course they do that yeah it's mind-boggling yeah so i guess that's the nature of progress yeah i guess maybe ai was able to just control that rocket with such efficiency that it makes it worth saving or something um my uh show topic or my second news is flutter flutter 1.0 and so flutter is is pretty interesting i've heard mixed reviews about it but but basically what flutter is um i don't know if we've talked about about reactjs or sorry, React Native. Yeah, okay. Oh, that's right.
以一种说不通的方式，现在却觉得‘哦，当然，他们就是那样做的’，这真是令人难以置信。是的，我想这就是进步的本质吧。也许人工智能能够以如此高的效率控制那枚火箭，以至于它变得值得挽救之类的。嗯，我的第二个新闻话题是Flutter 1.0。Flutter相当有趣，我听到过关于它的褒贬不一的评价，但基本上Flutter是……我不知道我们是否谈论过ReactJS，或者抱歉，是React Native。是的，好的。哦，没错。
We talked about all of that when we were talking about Clojure and there was Clojure script and all of that. So just to recap, React Native is where you write in a mix of HTML and JavaScript. But it's actually not HTML. It's XML, let's put it that way, and JavaScript. And then what happens, React Native ends up, basically, that code ends up driving a bunch of native components. So for example, if you have an XML tag button, then that's going to draw a button on the screen. And that tag takes attributes like text and things like that. And that tag can have children tags for all the different choices and things like that. So what happens under the hood is that button, XML tag,
我们在谈论Clojure时谈到过所有这些，还有ClojureScript等等。所以简单回顾一下，React Native是你用HTML和JavaScript的混合体来编写代码。但实际上它不是HTML，我们可以说是XML和JavaScript。然后发生的事情是，React Native最终基本上是用那段代码来驱动一系列原生组件。例如，如果你有一个XML标签button，那么它就会在屏幕上绘制一个按钮。该标签带有诸如文本之类的属性，并且该标签可以包含用于各种不同选项等的子标签。所以底层发生的事情是那个按钮，那个XML标签，
turns into an iOS button if it's built for iOS or an Android button, like a native button, right? Now, that's really cool. And it feels like a native app. You don't realize that the person hasn't written it in Objective-C or Swift or Java or Kotlin or one of these native libraries. So you don't know that the person has written it once for two phones or even more than two types of phones, but they have, right? Flutter takes a different approach. So Flutter is a little bit more like the web where, you know, you hope that all the browsers more or less behave the same. And so everything kind of looks the same. So if you go to Google.com on your phone and you go on your laptop, more or less it looks the same. And so Flutter, a button in Flutter is going to look exactly the same on Android and iOS.
如果是为 iOS 构建的，它就会变成 iOS 按钮，如果是为 Android 构建的，它就会变成 Android 按钮，就像原生按钮一样，对吧？这真的很酷。而且它感觉就像一个原生应用。你根本意识不到开发者不是用 Objective-C、Swift、Java、Kotlin 或这些原生库之一编写的。所以你不知道开发者其实只写了一次代码，就适配了两种甚至更多种手机，但他们确实做到了，对吧？Flutter 采用了不同的方法。Flutter 更像 Web，你知道的，你希望所有浏览器表现得大同小异。所以一切看起来都差不多。如果你在手机上访问 Google.com，再在笔记本电脑上访问，它们看起来基本是一样的。因此，Flutter 中的按钮在 Android 和 iOS 上看起来完全一样。
It's not going to match the theme of that hardware. And so the nice thing there is you when you're designing the layout so for example maybe on android you can fit three buttons across because just the the number of pixels and the border and the the padding and all that the buttons is is less and on ios you can only fit two buttons across but if you don't know that you're writing react native then then you when you deploy an iOS, it just doesn't look good. Like maybe it wraps around in some weird way. Maybe one of the buttons falls off the edge of the screen.
它不会去匹配硬件的主题。这样做的好处是，当你设计布局时，比如在 Android 上，你可能可以在一行放三个按钮，因为像素数量、边框、内边距等因素使得按钮占用空间较小；而在 iOS 上，你可能只能放两个按钮。但如果你在写 React Native 时不知道这一点，那么当你部署到 iOS 上时，它看起来就不太好。比如它可能会以某种奇怪的方式换行，或者其中一个按钮掉出了屏幕边缘。
And so you have to deal with all of those inconsistencies. Whereas for Flutter, it's almost pixel perfect, or pixel identical between the two. Now the downside of Flutter is that neither one of, it's never going to look native, right? So there's a sort of uncanny valley where, you know, it's like, okay, the buttons don't feel like regular native buttons. When you scroll, it doesn't really scroll with the same gravity. It doesn't have the same momentum and things just don't quite feel right. And so that's a trade-off, you know? I mean, you can't have iOS and Android look different. So like,
所以你必须处理所有这些不一致之处。而对于 Flutter，它几乎是像素完美的，或者说两者之间像素完全一致。现在 Flutter 的缺点是，它永远看起来都不像原生的，对吧？所以存在一种“恐怖谷”效应，你知道的，就是那种感觉——好吧，这些按钮感觉不像常规的原生按钮。当你滚动时，它的滚动阻尼感不一样。它没有同样的动量，一切感觉都不太对劲。这就是一种权衡，你知道吗？我的意思是，你不能让 iOS 和 Android 看起来不一样。所以，
you can't have something that looks the same on both and looks native, right? It's impossible, right? So Flutter makes a trade-off in one direction. React Native does it in the other direction. The jury's kind of still out, but I thought it was really interesting. And I think as a developer, one nice thing about Flutter is you can run it on, let's say, the iPhone simulator and then run it on an Android device. You don't necessarily need an iOS device because the look and feel and all of that is much more predefined. So yeah, check it out. I think it's pretty cool. It's getting a lot of traction.
你不可能让同一个东西在两者上看起来都一样，同时又看起来像原生的，对吧？这不可能，对吧？所以 Flutter 在一个方向上做了权衡，React Native 在另一个方向上做了权衡。目前还没有定论，但我认为这非常有趣。而且我认为作为开发者，Flutter 的一个好处是你可以先在 iPhone 模拟器上运行，然后再在 Android 设备上运行。你不一定需要 iOS 设备，因为它的外观、感觉和所有东西都更加预定义了。所以，去看看吧。我觉得它很酷，而且正在获得很多关注。
It's written in Dart, so you have to use the Dart programming language. But I think Dart is, correct me if I'm wrong, but I think Dart is like a superset of JavaScript. I don't know if that's true anymore. I know it's like, what did you call that? Transpilable to JavaScript. Yeah, it used to be a superset, but I think that's not true anymore. I think that not all JavaScript will just run as Dart code.
它是用 Dart 编写的，所以你必须使用 Dart 编程语言。但我认为 Dart 是——如果我说错了请纠正我——但我认为 Dart 就像是 JavaScript 的超集。我不知道现在还是不是这样。我知道它是，你管那叫什么来着？可以转译成 JavaScript。是的，它曾经是超集，但我认为现在不是了。我认为并非所有的 JavaScript 代码都能直接作为 Dart 代码运行。
But either way, I think it's cool. It's definitely worth trying out, especially if you're an app developer, and see how it compares to other frameworks. And let us know. If you build an app in Flutter, shoot us an email, post on Discord some cool pics, and we can check it out.
但无论如何，我认为它很酷。它绝对值得一试，特别是如果你是一名应用开发者，看看它与其他框架相比如何。并让我们知道。如果你用 Flutter 构建了一个应用，给我们发封邮件，在 Discord 上发些酷图，我们可以看看。
All right, man. I think it's that time. Time for another giveaway. Five giveaways. so now the next five uh just to recap we're gonna send you all emails um you can uh choose a t-shirt we'll send you a t-shirt from the store we'll send you a book one of the books of the show of your choosing um for those two you'll have to give us your address if it's not already in patreon uh or you can opt for an ebook so any of our books of the show that are available on kindle uh we'll figure out a way to get that too so we have christopher from west virginia we got steve
好了，伙计。我想是时候了。又到了赠送礼物的环节。五个赠品。那么接下来的五个，呃，简单回顾一下，我们会给你们所有人发邮件，你们可以选一件 T 恤，我们会从商店寄给你；我们会送你一本书，你可以从节目推荐的书单里选一本。对于这两样，如果你的地址还没在 Patreon 上，你得提供给我们；或者你可以选择电子书，任何我们在 Kindle 上有的节目推荐书籍，我们会想办法送给你。所以我们有来自西弗吉尼亚州的克里斯托弗，我们有史蒂夫。
uh steve p we have alisar from um interesting al Alisar from Merseyside. I don't actually know what that is. Is that a country? I don't know, but we'll find out. Andre, who is from, looks like, Jorbiti. And Jonas, who's from Denmark. So congratulations. I'll send emails to you guys um later on today looks like mercyside is a county in uh in england oh there you go or so says uh my google search and wikipedia it's interesting this this this column is really noisy i don't know why
呃，史蒂夫·P，我们有来自，呃，有趣的，来自默西赛德郡的阿丽萨。我其实不知道那是什么地方。那是一个国家吗？我不知道，但我们会查清楚的。安德烈，他来自，看起来像是，Jorbiti。还有来自丹麦的乔纳斯。所以恭喜你们。我今天晚些时候会给你们发邮件。看起来默西赛德郡是英格兰的一个郡，哦，原来如此，或者我的谷歌搜索和维基百科是这么说的。有趣的是，这个 Patreon 报告里的这一列真的很乱，我不知道为什么。
that is but but you know there's one column in this Patreon report. It has states for some people. It has countries for other people. It must be just like, when people fill out the form, there must be this field that's just principality or something. Or maybe it's pulling it out of a string.
是这样，但你知道，Patreon 报告里有一列。有些人填的是州，有些人填的是国家。这一定是因为，当人们填写表格时，一定有一个字段只是“公国”之类的。或者它可能是从一个字符串里提取出来的。
I don't know. But congratulations you folks, and I'll send that information out to you pretty soon. All right, cool. Well, we're going to do one more little activity here. And then we'll draw the final five names. So I found an article, and I had it as the article of the show. And then I decided to actually read through these and see.
我不知道。但恭喜你们，我会很快把信息发给你们。好了，酷。我们要在这里再做一个小活动。然后我们会抽出最后五个名字。所以我找到了一篇文章，我把它作为节目推荐文章。然后我决定实际读一下这些内容看看。
Well, Jason hasn't read these yet. And so we're going to see how he responds to this. And this is an article describing a person who learned programming at an early age, but wrote, hey, here's some thoughts I had about the difference between programming and working as a professional software engineer. Nobody really told me these. Some of them are very on point. I think some of them might be a little more interesting.
嗯，杰森还没读过这些。所以我们要看看他对此有什么反应。这是一篇描述一个人在很小的时候就学习编程的文章，但他写道：“嘿，这是我关于编程和作为专业软件工程师工作之间区别的一些想法。”没人真正告诉过我这些。其中一些非常到位。我认为其中一些可能更有趣。
We won't necessarily read all of them But that you know, I'm gonna read a couple here and see what what Jason thinks All right. So here the number one Jason is it's normal to have more lines of tests than production code That's a tough one, I mean he's definitely close Really? I feel like it's true to more lines of tests and production code. If you're writing good tests, if you're actually writing unit tests for your code. Wait, so you feel like the answer is yes? Like you agree with that?
我们不一定会读完所有内容，但我会在这里读几条，看看杰森怎么想。好了。第一条，杰森，测试代码比生产代码多是很正常的。这是一个难题，我的意思是，他肯定很接近。真的吗？我觉得测试代码比生产代码多是真的。如果你在写好的测试，如果你真的在为你的代码编写单元测试的话。等等，所以你觉得答案是肯定的？就像你同意这一点？
For code that you are writing unit tests for, yes. I feel the answer is yes. So you're saying there's more unit test code than actual code? Yes. Yeah, I believe it. Yeah, I'm having a hard time visualizing that because a lot of the unit test code is a little bit more boilerplate. But yeah, I think that's true. I agree with that.
对于你正在编写单元测试的代码，是的。我觉得答案是肯定的。所以你是说单元测试代码比实际代码多？是的。是的，我相信。是的，我很难想象这一点，因为很多单元测试代码有点像样板代码。但是的，我认为这是真的。我同意这一点。
All right, cool. Having no choice but to use VI early in this person's career, they meant that now they're stuck using those key bindings everywhere. Yeah, I disagree with that. I mean, I definitely got started with Emacs, but... Oh, here it goes. Well, no, I mean, I've never switched to VI, but I did switch from Emacs to visual IDEs,
好了，酷。由于职业生涯早期别无选择只能使用 VI，这意味着现在他们被困在到处使用这些快捷键了。是的，我不同意这一点。我的意思是，我确实是从 Emacs 开始的，但是……哦，来了。好吧，不，我的意思是，我从来没有切换到 VI，但我确实从 Emacs 切换到了可视化 IDE，
like Atom and Visual Studio Code and these things. And to be honest, I haven't turned on the Emacs bindings. Now, there are times where I do like, yeah, like control X, right button and nothing happens or I'll literally draw an X on the screen. Now I'm kind of like, oh, I need to set up the Emacs key bindings, but I never actually do. So, yeah, I mean, personally, i don't seem to have locked in any of these key bindings what about you yes i was gonna say i think i read this more as like you'll lock
比如 Atom 和 Visual Studio Code 之类的东西。老实说，我没有开启 Emacs 绑定。现在，有时候我确实会，比如，按下 Ctrl+X，右键，什么也没发生，或者我会在屏幕上画一个 X。现在我有点像，哦，我需要设置 Emacs 快捷键，但我从来没真正做过。所以，是的，我的意思是，就我个人而言，我似乎没有锁定任何这些快捷键。你呢？是的，我正想说，我觉得我读到的是，你会锁定一种做事方式，然后被困在那里。是的，我不知道，我也不太同意这一点。是的，这对我来说并没有真正发生。我绝对能看出这在一般情况下会发生，但就我个人而言，它没有发生。好了，酷。呃，是的，所以我在这里挑挑拣拣，但是，哦，这里，你做同样的工作，根据你在小型初创公司还是大公司工作，基本工资可能会有 100% 的差异。100% 的基本工资，我想这意味着你在初创公司拿到的钱可能只有你在大公司工作时能赚到的一半，而且是基本工资。是的，我的意思是，我觉得这只是，这只是一个事实，对吧？我的意思是，这是一个事实。
into a way of doing things and be stuck that way yeah i don't know i don't know i agree with that either yeah it just hasn't really happened for me i definitely could see it happening in general but personally it hasn't happened all right cool uh yeah so i'm picking and choosing here but um that oh here you could have a hundred percent base salary difference doing the same job depending on whether you work at a small startup or at a big company hundred percent base i think that means you could be paid half as much at a startup as what you could earn if you went and worked at a big company and base salary yeah i mean i feel like that's just that's just a, right? I mean, it's a fact.
是的，我认为这是真的。我的意思是，初创公司是这些高风险的事情之一，这是一种风险与，你知道，就像你不会，初创公司的全部意义在于你拥有初创公司的一大块股份。但是的，这很公平。是的。
Yeah, I think it's true. I mean, the startup is one of these risky, it's a risk versus, you know, like you're not gonna, the whole point of the startup is you own some big chunk of the startup. But yeah, that's fair. Yeah.
所以，我的意思是，我认为这是很多人不知道的事情。我认为这是真的。我认为它可能到处都是。但我认为总的来说，是的，初创公司的薪水比大公司低得多。这是一个很好的观点。你知道，我只是把它当作理所当然。但是，你知道，如果我刚从大学毕业，我可能不会意识到这一点。
So, I mean, I think that's something not a lot of people would know. I think it is true. I think that it can be all over the place. But I think in general, yeah, startups pay much less than big companies. That's a really good point. You know, I just took it for granted. But, you know, if I was straight out of college, I probably wouldn't have realized that.
但是，是的，我的意思是，在我看来，告诉我你对此怎么看。我认为刚从大学毕业就加入初创公司是很疯狂的。我的意思是，那些变得非常大的初创公司，比如谷歌和 Facebook，当然，它们是由那些在大学里或从大学辍学的人创立的，或者诸如此类。但首先，这些人是创始人，对吧？其次，那是极少数极少数的初创公司，对吧？绝大多数初创公司实际上，你知道，它们做得还不错。它们最终只是中型企业，或者被大公司收购了。但我不觉得它们有那种
But yeah, I mean, in my opinion, and tell me what you think about this. I think it's crazy to join a startup straight out of college. I mean, the startups that get really big, like the Googles and Facebook, sure, they're founded by people who are either in college or dropping out of college or what have you. But first of all, those people are the founders, right? And secondly, that's the vast, vast minority of startups, right? The vast majority of startups are actually, you know, they do reasonably well. They end up just mid-sized businesses or they get acquired by a bigger company. But I don't feel like they have that
谷歌或 Facebook 作为初创公司所拥有的巨大上升空间。所以，是的，我的意思是，如果你没有意识到存在巨大的风险，那么在我看来，你可能应该去一家更大的公司。是的，我想也是。我个人对此感到好奇。所以我得说，你应该做适合你的事情。所以如果大学毕业后，你真的对初创公司感兴趣，而且初创公司非常适合你，我不认为有什么损失，比如去初创公司并不意味着你永远不会去大公司工作。但我认为你必须意识到，这实际上将是这里的另一个要点，那就是你实际花在编码上的时间与各种各样的任务相比，这不是这个人的确切观点，但是，我认为你花在编码上的时间相对于一整套其他任务，
enormous upside that a Google or Facebook as a startup has. And so, yeah, I mean, if you don't realize that there's a huge risk, then probably you should be at a bigger company, in my opinion. Yeah, I think so. I've personally wondered about this. So I'll say that you should do the thing that's right for you. So if out of college, you're really interested in a startup and a startup is a good fit for what you're, I don't think there's anything to lose per se, like going to a startup isn't going to mean you never go work at a big company. But I think you have to realize that, and this is actually going to be another one of the points uh in here uh is that how much time you actually spend coding versus a whole variety of tasks this is not exactly this person's point but um i think the amount of time you spend coding relative to a whole suite of other tasks
在你的职位、你的角色、你当前的团队以及初创公司和大公司之间是不同的。所以在大公司，你知道，你可能会发现自己经常在与公司强制要求的构建系统作斗争；而初创公司，可能就像是，哦，我直接放弃那个，去用另一个构建系统，因为为什么不呢？所以，我认为你可能学到了实际的编码，我不知道。我从来没在初创公司工作过。它可能非常相似。你写的实际的 Java 或 C++ 或 Python 可能非常相似。但围绕它的背景，测试量，速度，灵活性，我认为这些东西可能非常不同。所以我不知道它总是多么直接地
is uh varied across your position across your role across your current team and between startups and big companies so at a big company you know you might find yourself often fighting with build systems that are mandated by your company uh whereas a startup it might be like oh i just ditch that go use a different build system because why not um and so i think that you might learn the actual coding i don don't know. I've never worked at a startup. It might be quite similar. The actual like Java or C++ or Python you write might be pretty similar. But the context around it, the amount of testing, the amount of speed, the flexibility, I think those things can be very different. And so I'm not sure how directly
可转移。是的，这很有道理。我的意思是，我认为在初创公司，你是在试图找到合适的产品市场契合点。所以简单回顾一下，我的意思是，不是要在初创公司上花一整期节目，但初创公司的全部意义在于找到一个垄断，比如从一个非常非常小的垄断开始。也许你的垄断是在你的城市。你知道，你们是做传真的人，把传真转换成电子邮件。而且无论出于什么原因，也许是因为营销。也许是因为你在家乡很有名。我不知道，随便什么。但无论出于什么原因，你只是拥有了那个市场的大量份额，70% 的市场份额。你拥有垄断地位。然后问题是，你能扩大那个市场吗？你能最终拥有，你知道，
transferable it always is. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, I think at a startup, you're trying to find the right product market fit. So just to recap, I mean, not to spend a whole show on startups, but the whole point of a startup is to find a monopoly, like start with a very, very tiny monopoly. Maybe your monopoly is in your city. You know, you are the people that do fax, converting faxes to emails. And for whatever reason, maybe it's because of marketing. Maybe it's because you're famous in your hometown. I don't know, whatever. But for whatever reason, you just own a ton of that market, 70% of that market. You have a monopoly. And then the question is, can you grow grow that market and can you end up with you know
所有出租车的垄断地位或者其他什么。我想优步，当我提到垄断时，我有点在挥手，我在挥手示意。我的意思是，显然优步没有垄断，你完全可以下载 Lyft，但实际上，你能把这个市场里的人的空间减少到少数几个人吗？而且这是一个巨大的市场，对吧？所以当你这样做的时候，你知道，你可能会彻底改变软件，所以测试之类的事情可能不像你，如果你在初创公司，你可能会写出相当随意的代码，这就是我会预料到的。我从来没有作为一个概括，是的，我的意思是，我觉得那通常会是，我的意思是，这取决于，如果初创公司是
a monopoly of of uh you know all taxi drive all taxi cabs or something i guess uber when i say monopoly like i'm kind of waving i'm waving my hands a little bit i mean obviously uber doesn't have a monopoly you can just download lyft but like effectively can can you reduce the the space of people who are in this in this in this in this market to like a handful of people and is it a huge market right and so while you're doing that you know you might be radically changing the software and so tests and things like that might not be as important as you're probably if you're in a startup you'll probably be writing pretty cavalier code that that's what i would expect i've never as a generalization yeah i mean i feel like that would generally be i mean it depends now if the startup is
医疗设备，你知道，请写一个心脏起搏器之类的东西，那完全不同。但我感觉总的来说，很多这些初创公司，我觉得你会写出相当随意的代码，特别是如果是产品代码而不是像数据库那样的东西。所以离开初创公司，我认为他们在这里提到的另一个有趣的观点是，不同的角色可以被重视。哦，他们在这里说，来了，在你的当地文化中，在你们公司的当地文化中，有不同的声望。所以说你是测试工程师，或者自动化，或者前端，或者 Web，或者数据库，或者优化，或者底层编译器人员，无论你说的你做的那种事情，都会极大地影响人们对你的看法。我稍微阐述了一下他们的观点，但你对此感觉如何？是的，我的意思是，我想我有点希望它更正式一点。而且我认为我们正在
medical equipment you know to please write like a pacemaker or something that's totally different but i feel like in general a lot of these startups, I feel like you're going to be writing pretty cavalier code, especially if it's product code and not like a database. So getting off of the startups, another interesting point that I thought they had here that was good was that different roles can be valued. Oh, here they say, here it goes, have different cachet that in your local culture, in the local culture of your company. So saying you're a test engineer or an automation or front end or web or database or an optimization, a low level compiler guy, like whatever the kind of thing you say you do can vastly impact how people feel about you. I'm expounding a little on their point, but how do you feel about that? Yeah, I mean, I think I kind of wish it was a little bit more formal. And I think we're getting
到达那里。我们还没完全到那一步。但这有点奇怪。我的意思是，我会收到某人的邮件，他们会说，嘿，我们正在为这家公司寻找软件工程师。然后你看看职位描述，它是，哦，需要能够编写，你知道，摩托罗拉汇编，或者需要非常了解优化数据库，这些东西，我对此一无所知。所以，你知道，我实际上希望这些他们称之为，听起来他们让它看起来更像是一个社会标签的东西，对吧？但我们应该走得更远，让软件工程工作稍微分层一点，对吧？
there. We're not quite there yet. But it's kind of weird. I mean, I'll get an email from someone and they'll say, hey, we're looking for a software engineer for this company. And then you look at the job description and it's, oh oh needs to be able to to write you know Motorola assembly or needs to know a whole lot about optimizing a database these things which which I've literally known nothing about um and so you know I'm hoping actually that these things that they're calling kind of it sounds like they're they're making it seem more like a social label, right? But we should just go so far as to make it stratify the software engineering job a little bit, right?
我认为这双向都有影响。我认为你可以说，哦，那个人所做的只是 blah。那个人所做的只是写前端代码。他们不是真正的工程师。而且我猜对于你所说的关于分层，是的，我认为这可能会变得危险，因为我认为你需要的技能集可能，我不是说这是真的，我只是要发明一些东西作为概括，但要说，比如，哦，写前端，哦，那没那么技术性，而且你甚至不需要知道微分方程
I think it cuts both ways. I think that you can say, oh, all that person does is blah. All that person does is write front-end code. They're not a real engineer uh and i guess to what you're saying about stratifying yeah i think that can become dangerous because i think the skill set you need there might be and i'm not saying this is true i'm just going to invent something as a generalization but to say like oh right in front end oh that's not as technical and that you you don't even need to know differential equations
来做那个。而且就像，好吧，那可能是真的。但这也意味着要与艺术家合作，不断地大幅改变需求，并且要有设计眼光，因为你并不总是拥有设计师供你支配。这可能意味着一种实际上相当困难且难以做到的技能集。但你知道，研究，你知道，编译器优化理论，以及它的符号逻辑或任何东西，你知道，也许那是一件更学术的事情，但事实证明，是的，那是非常严谨和困难的，而且这些谜题非常非常难找到，而且取得进展是断断续续的，而不是，你知道，UI 模型。
to do that and it's like well that might be't even need to know differential equations to do that. And it's like, well, that might be true. But it also means working with artists and constantly vastly changing requirements and having an eye for design because you don't always have the designer at your disposal. It might mean a skill set that's actually quite difficult and hard to do um but you know working on you know compiler optimization theory uh and the symbolic logic of that or whatever you know maybe that is a much more academic thing but it turns out like yeah that's very rigorous and difficult and those puzzles are very very hard to find and making progress comes in you know spur, spurts rather than, you know, UI mocks.
但这并不，分层很奇怪，因为分层意味着几乎是一种严格的排序。我不知道那是不是正确的词，但就像，我不知道它是否严格地这个比那个好。可能是不同的人适合不同的。是的，分层完全是错误的词。我认为它更像是，我在寻找什么词，它只是聚类，或者只是拆分出来，这样前端工程师，如果有人想要一个前端工程师，他们就不会把东西放在上面。更明确的角色，比如更多的细微差别，角色中更多的粒度。是的，完全正确。现在，一个不幸的事情是，任何时候你给两件不同的事情贴上两个不同的标签，最终都会出现等级制度。对。如果没什么别的，这两个工作的供需动态会不同，这会导致薪水不同，这会导致等级制度，对吧？我的意思是，但这已经发生了，对吧？所以通过隐藏在软件工程师的标签下，它实际上只是让人们更难倡导
But that doesn't stratification is weird because stratification implies like almost a strict ordering. And I don't know that I know that's the right word, but like I don't know that it's strictly this one's better than another. It might be different people are suited to different. Yeah, stratification is totally the wrong word. I think it's more like, what's the word I'm looking for where it's just clustering or just split out so that front-end engineer, like if someone wants a front-end engineer, they don't put stuff on. More defined roles, like more nuance, more granularity in the roles. Yeah, exactly. Now, one unfortunate thing is that is that any time you put two different labels on two different things, there's going to end up being a hierarchy. Right. Like if nothing else, the supply and demand dynamics of those two jobs will be different and that will cause the pay to be different and that will cause a hierarchy, right? I mean, but that happens already, right? So by sort of hiding under the software engineer label, it actually just makes it harder for people to advocate for
更好的薪水之类的事情，因为它只是增加了更多的差异，对吧？但是的，说到你的观点，我不认为，我认为假设这些工作中的任何一个比其他任何一个更好都是错误的。我的意思是，它们都，它们都某种程度上需要一套不同的技能。但你是对的。我不想，我不想把它拖进一场巨大的谈话中。但你是对的，它们是不同的。一个可能更好或更坏，或更难或更容易。但供需会决定价格可能不同。比如薪水。是的。是的。所以，是的，我也可以从两方面来看。我个人仍然倾向于，为什么不呢？我的意思是，特别是如果我们
better salaries and things like that, because it just adds more variance, right? But yeah, to your point, I don't think, I think it would be wrong to assume that any of those jobs is better than any other one. I mean, they're they're all they're all sort of require a different set of skills. But you are right. I don't. And without getting in, I don't want to drag it onto a giant conversation. But you are right that they're different. One may be better or worse or harder or easier. But supply and demand will dictate that prices might be different. Like the pay. Yep. Yep. So, yeah. so I can see it both ways as well I personally still lean towards like why not I mean especially if we if
软件工程师成为，我的意思是，让我们想象一下在未来，全球 10% 的员工是软件工程师。我的意思是，这显然离我们现在生活的宇宙远得多，对吧？但假设发生了这种情况，对吧？我的意思是，你不能只把软件工程师作为职位名称。那将是荒谬的，对吧？所以，你知道，我认为随着那个工作变得越来越普遍，最终那将不得不发生。所以，我的意思是，我想我猜在即兴发挥中试图想出一个类比，
software engineer becomes I mean let's imagine in the future 10% of all employees globally our software engineers I mean that's that's obviously what much farther from the universe we're living in now, right? But let's say that happened, right? I mean, you can't just have software engineer as a job title then. It would be absurd, right? And so, you know, I think that as that job becomes more and more prevalent, eventually that will have to happen. So, I mean, I think that I guess on the fly trying to come up with an analogy,
如果你谈论一名医生，所以人们仍然说你是医生，但有儿科医生，有外科医生，有心脏病专家，还有全科医生。我的意思是，我不是，我不是专家。是的。对。
if you talk about a medical doctor, so people still say you're a doctor, but there's pediatricians and there's surgeons and there's cardiologists and there's general practitioner. I mean, I'm not, I'm not an expert. Yeah. Right.
你有所有这些不同的东西。如果你看职位描述，它可能不会说医生，对吧？对。但你仍然会，其他人可能会那样称呼它，即使他们知道有更多的细微差别，你仍然会说，哦，你是医生。对，但你仍然会，其他人可能会那样称呼它，即使他们知道有更多的细微差别，你仍然会说，哦，你是医生，就像你
You have all these different things. If you looked at a job description, it probably wouldn't say doctor, right? Right. But you would still, other people might call it that even if they know there's more nuance, you'd still say, Oh, you're a doctor right but you would still other people might call it that even if they know there's more nuance you'd still say oh you're a doctor like you're
仍然是那个东西，你仍然是医生，你仍然去医学院，但随后你发展了一个专业，你是对的，一份工作邀请会非常清楚地说明，嘿，这是一个职位，你知道，在医院工作作为脊椎按摩外科医生，我不知道，我很糟糕，无论如何，我也不知道那是什么，但你知道，它会非常具体地说明那份工作是什么。它会有一个好的标签，因为它是一种稳定的东西，每个人都知道它意味着什么。但可能确实，比如儿科医生赚的钱不如脑外科医生多，尽管事实上人们都称他们为医生，而且他们可能都称自己为医生。是的，我同意这一点。酷，下一个，或者另一个是，最好的技术并不总是获胜。事实上，它往往不会。有趣，最好的，什么
still that thing you're still a doctor you still go to medical school but then you develop a specialization and you're right a job offer would be very clear about hey this is a position for you know working in the hospital as a chiropractic surgeon i don't i'm terrible anyways i don't know what that is either but but you know it's going to say very specifically what that job is it's going to have a good label because it's a sort of stable thing and everyone knows what it means um but it's probably true that like a pediatrician doesn't make as much money as a brain surgeon despite the fact that people both call them doctors and they probably both refer to themselves as doctors yeah i agree with that cool next one or another one is that the best technology doesn't always win in fact it often doesn't interesting the best what's
再说一遍，最好的技术，技术不一定获胜。事实上，它往往不会。哈，我从来没想过那个。好吧，我的意思是，你对此有什么看法？我需要仔细考虑一下。哦，我的意思是，我觉得那是，是的，那绝对是真的，对吧？比如最好的网站，或者把它当作一种编程语言，人们总是说 Lisp，Lisp 很棒，好吧，这很酷。而且有些人会说它是最好的，但即使它是否是最好的也是有争议的。但即使你相信它是最好的，或者即使它是最好的，一大堆事情、条件、背景、企业支持都会影响该技术是否胜出。是的，我的意思是，绝对。我的意思是，这个陈述很弱，因为，你知道，最好的只是一件事。而且有太多的噪音，以至于就像说，
that one more time the best technology technology doesn't necessarily win in fact it often doesn't huh i know i never i never thought about that well i mean what's your take on that i need to mull on that a little bit oh i mean i feel like that's yeah that's definitely true right like the best website or take it like a programming language people are always like lisp lisp is amazing well this is pretty cool uh and some people would say it's the best but even if whether or not it's the best is arguable. But even if you believe it is best or even if it was the best, a whole host of things, conditions, context, corporate backing get into whether or not that technology wins out. Yeah, I mean, definitely. I mean, the statement is weak in the sense that, you know, the best is just one thing. And there's so much noise that it's like saying,
挑选任何品质。那一种品质并不能保证成功，无论它是什么，或者即使你如何定义最好，对吧？但总的来说，我的意思是，我绝对认为更好的语言会成功。就像我认为没那么好的语言。那甚至是真的吗？
pick any quality. That one quality isn't going to guarantee success, no matter what it is, or even however you compose best, right? But in general, I mean, I definitely think better languages succeed. Like I think languages that aren't as good. Is that even true?
不，我不这么认为。我的意思是，我认为这是一个真实的陈述。正如你指出的，它可能很弱，因为证明“最好”有点难，对吧？所以，比如，你会说，我的意思是，让我们看看顶级语言。比如 C++，JavaScript，Java，Ruby。那些，你知道，比平均语言更好还是更差？它们可能更好，是的。然后最好的，可能还有其他一些是最好的，但没有得到支持，或者领先于时代，或者，你知道，插入一大堆其他原因，它们在排名前 15 吗？哦，我不知道，伙计。
No, I don't. I mean, I think it's a true statement. As you point out, it might be weak in that it's a little hard to prove best, right? So, like, would you say, I mean, let's take the top languages. Let's say C++, JavaScript, Java, Ruby. Are those, you know, better or worse than an average language than an average they're probably better yeah then the best there are probably other ones that are best but didn't get backing or were ahead of their time or uh you know insert a whole host of other reasons that are they in the top let's say 15 oh i don't know man
因为我觉得很多人创造了很多语言，却从来没有某种程度上完全执行这个想法。是的，那是真的。所以我认为这很困难，但我的意思是，看看外面的，让我们看看网站，对吧？比如，呃，难道不是真的吗？拥有最好、最多，比如最快、最准确体育比分的网站，体育世界中事件发生与他们更新比分之间的延迟，并不一定意味着那个网站会成为每个人查看体育比分的方式。大多数人仍然会去 ESPN 或任何相当于你所在运动的广播，可能在欧洲，因为那有营销，它已经有了有机流量。而且只要如果那些体育比分足够好，你可能会围绕你的特定，正如你所说的，你对最好的定义，比如我有
because i feel like a lot of people create a lot of languages and don't ever sort of fully execute on the idea yeah that's true so i that's difficult but i mean look out there in in let's take websites right like um uh isn't true that the site with the best, most, let's say the quickest and most accurate sports scores, the latency between event happening in the sports world and their update of the score, doesn't necessarily mean that that website will become how everybody checks sports scores. Most people are still going to go to ESPN or whatever equivalent for your sport broadcasting might be in Europe, because that has marketing, it has already organic traffic. And as long as if those sports scores are good enough, you might cultivate a crowd around your specific, as you said, your definition of best, like I have
最低的延迟和最高的准确性，但这并不能保证你会获得流量。是的，我认为这很有道理。是的。所以我认为，你知道，总的来说，非常流行的语言是好的。嗯，它们是最好的吗？是的，没门。因为正如你所说的，有太多其他因素了。是的。嗯，让我们看看还有没有其他的，哦，这里有一个，呃，表情符号的适当使用将成为一项非常重要的沟通技巧。表情符号的适当使用将成为一项非常，不，我真的不，我的意思是，这只是我。也许这是一种代际差异，但我老实说不使用表情符号。
the lowest latency and highest accuracy, but that doesn't guarantee you're going to get traffic. Yeah, I think it makes sense. Yeah. So I think, you know, in general, really popular languages are good. Um, are they the best? Yeah, there's no way. Cause as you said, there's too many other factors. Yeah. Um, let's see if there's any other, Oh, here's a kind of two, the appropriate use of emojis would become a very important communication skill. The appropriate use of emojis would become a very, no, I don't really, I mean, it's just me. Maybe it's like a generational thing, but I don't use emojis, to be honest.
我的意思是，我有时会用笑脸，但几乎所有东西，比如我上次做除了笑脸以外的任何事情是什么时候？而且我和你谈了大概十年了。有道理。不过那只是我，我使用那种翻桌子的表情符号，那个家伙，他像那样把它翻过来。哦，是的，那个很难画，除非你把它保存在某处。我只是复制那个翻桌子的，还有那个耸肩的，ASCII 艺术耸肩的家伙，那些就像我的，那些是我的首选表情符号。我必须承认，我真的很喜欢那两个。嗯，但它们个人没有理由，什么，是的，我的意思是，当我看到
I mean, I'll use the smiley face sometimes, but almost everything, like when's the last time I did anything other than a smiley face? And I've been talking to you for like a decade. Fair enough. That's just me though i use the table flipping emoji thing where the guy and he like flips it down like that oh yeah that one's hard to draw unless you have it saved somewhere i just copy the table flipping one and the guy shrugging the ascii art shrugging guy those are like my those are my go-to emojis i have to admit i really like both of those um but they have no reason personally what yeah i mean when i see
有人做翻桌子，它合法地让我笑。所以，我的意思是，我从中得到了很多价值，但我只是，你知道，没有花时间去把它做成宏，而且我总是太懒了，不想在对话中搜索它。所以我没有机会使用它。也许如果有人对我使用它，而且速度足够快，我可以找到它并对他们使用它，我会做的。好了，等等，等等，给我两秒钟。
someone do the table flipping it legit it legitimately makes me laugh so i mean i i get a lot of value out of it but i just i haven't you know taken the time to macro it and i never i'm always too lazy to search it like in, in the middle of a conversation. So I haven't had a chance to use it. Maybe if someone used it on me, and it was quick enough where I could get to it and use it back on them, I would do it. All right, hang on, hang on, give me two seconds.
我要发短信给你。我需要一个翻桌子，比如，字面上是一个翻桌子的表情符号，你知道，就像在键盘里，所以如果我知道，如果我在键盘的托盘里，我可以选择翻桌子，我可能会做，就像你替换字母 I，谁需要字母 I，直接把它做出来，翻桌子里没有 I。哦，帕特里克刚发给我翻桌子。这是一个非常好的。这就像一个非常花哨的，比如……是的，那看起来确实很花哨。这不是普通的那个。
I'm going to text it to you. I need a table-flipping, like, literally a table-flipping emoji, you know, like in the keyboard so so if you know if in the tray of the keyboard i could choose table flipping i'd probably do it like you replace the letter i like who needs the letter i just make it there's no i in table flipping oh patrick just sent me the table flipping this This is a really good one. This is like a really fancy, like... Yeah, that does look fancy. This is not the normal one.
好吧。我想是时候了，伙计。我想我们需要另外五个。哇，那个很花哨。他有一个代表鼻子的符号。多么有趣的鼻子。所以现在我只是在发送……我找到了一个网站，上面有一大堆
Okay. I think it's time, man. I think we need another five. Wow, that one is fancy. He has a symbol for his nose. What an interesting nose. So now I'm just sending... I found a website that has like a whole bunch of
随机的翻桌子表情符号，来自 Unicode 字符。所以这里面有一些非常好的。好吧。我们可以在这里的节目说明中放一个链接。我会添加一个链接到这个。这很好。你只要把这个页面加入书签，杰森，你的生活至少会好一百倍，至少保证，否则退款。是的。我认为人们现在真的会在工作中的小组对话中听我说话了。是的。好吧，酷。好了。我不需要只是说，我不需要只是说我告诉过你，一直。人们听了。哦，伙计。嗯，好了，所以我们的最后获奖者，好吧，首先，感谢大家的注册。我们有已经成为赞助人一段时间的人，实际上让我来看一下
random table flipping emoji out of the Unicode characters. And so there's some really good ones in here. Okay. We can put a link in the show notes here. I'll add a link to this. This is good. You just bookmark this page, Jason, and your life will be at least a hundred times better, at least guaranteed or your money back. Yeah. I think people will actually listen to me in group conversations at work now. Yes. Okay, cool. All right. I don now yes okay cool all right i don't have to just say i don't have to just say i told you so all the time people have listened oh man um all right so our last winners well first of all thanks everyone for signing up we have people who have been patrons for a while actually let me take a
那个，呃，我没有，我没有办法在脑子里看那个。我们明年得做。哦，是的，明年我们应该有类别，比如五个人基于他们待了多久，五个人基于地理分布，我们应该有那个，那会很酷。是的，到明年我不会记得那个。我想，好吧，地理是一个好主意。我考虑过基于他们待了多久来做，但，但我有一种感觉，那些人已经赢了一些我们真的很长时间的，是的，我看了名字，其中一些我认出来了。嗯，是的，我记得已经给他们寄过礼物了。所以我，是的，在最后一刻我有点没做那个，但好吧，没有一种方法可以公平地切分，对吧？所以这就像，我想，和任何事情一样公平。
look at that uh i don't have i don't have a way to look at that off the top of my head we'll have to do it next year oh yeah next year we should have like categories like five people based on like how long they've been there five people based on like distributing by geography like we should have that'd be cool yeah i won't remember that by next year i thought well geography is a good idea i thought about doing it based on how long they've been there but but i have a feeling those people have already won like some of our really long time yeah i looked at the names and some of them i recognized um yeah i remember sending gifts to them already so so i yeah at the last minute i kind of didn't do that but well there's no one way to cut it fair, right? So this is as fair, I guess, as anything.
均匀随机。无法击败它。好了。所以这个人的姓是 NPC。我不知道。我有一种感觉那不是真的。他们是机器人。他们是机器人。
Uniform random. Can't beat it. All right. So this person's last name is NPC. I don't know. I have a feeling that's not real. They're a bot. They're a bot.
但无论如何我们都要把它给你，而且，呃，我不会宣布溢出的人，因为我不想，你知道，你没意识到，哦，我是第一个没得到它的人。哦，是的，但如果，但如果，但如果 NPC 没得到它，你将是别人，我们一定会确保 15 个人得到奖品。这就是，这就是。是的，就是这样。但格伦 NPC，他没有地址。格伦，你，你排在第 11 位。来自英国的史蒂芬。
But we're going to give it to you anyways and um uh i'm not gonna announce the the people in the overflow um because i don't want you know you didn't realize oh i was the first person who didn't get it oh yeah but if but if but if npc doesn't get it uh you will be someone else we'll definitely make sure 15 people get prizes. That's what that's what. Yeah, there we go. But Glenn NPC, who doesn't have an address. Glenn, you are you're coming in number 11. Stephen from the UK.
托马斯 K。我们也没有来自英国的保罗的地址。还有克里斯，克里斯 L。所以这些是我们的获奖者。我会给你们所有人发邮件。并插入掌声，来自人群的鼓掌。是的，实际上。是的，我不能。
Thomas K. We don't have an address for Paul from the UK as well. And Chris, Chris L. So those are our winners. I'll be sending all of you folks emails. And insert applause, clapping from the crowd. Yeah, actually. Yeah, I can't.
我不会透露任何人的电子邮件。那是不对的。但，但你们有一些搞笑的电子邮件。恭喜你们。如果你是 Programming Throwdown 的赞助人，你会想出一些相当不错的电子邮件地址。所以给你们点赞。酷。好了。
I'm not going to reveal anyone's email. That wouldn't be right. But but you have some hilarious emails. Congrats on you. If you're a patron of Programming Throwdown, you come up with some pretty good email addresses. So props to you on that. Cool. All right.
嗯，我们最终没有找到任何愿意参与录音的人。是的，有人，呃，这里有观众，但，但我觉得人们有点害羞。我实际上，我不想只是随机打开麦克风，人们只是像，哦，啊。所以，我发布了，呃，有没有人想加入聊天，有些人很害羞。我认为这很有道理。它被永远录下来了。它在一个 MP3 里。跟我说说。我知道。
Well, we didn't end up with anybody who was willing to participate in recording. Yeah, there's someone who uh there's a there's an audience here but uh but i think there's people are a little bit shy i actually i didn't want to just randomly open the mic up and people just be like oh ah so so i i posted uh um does anybody want to to join the chat and some people are gun-shy. I think it makes sense. It's recorded forever. It's in an MP3. Tell me about it. I know.
在互联网上，你的一生。我不怪你，但一定要在 Discord 上保持聊天。我们回答了所有问题。我们实际上回答了 Discord 上人们问的每一个问题。再次恭喜我们的获奖者，而且，呃，你们有一个很棒的，呃，假期，圣诞快乐，新年快乐，快乐，呃，光明节。哦，我发现有一个东西叫 Ed 或 Eid 之类的，它就像一个，它是一个，它是一个，它是一个节日传统，我其实不太了解它
On the internet for your entire life. I don't blame you, but definitely keep up chatting on the Discord. We answer all of the questions. We literally answered every question on the Discord that people have asked. Congrats again to our winners and uh you have a great um holidays merry christmas happy new year happy uh hanukkah oh i found there's this thing called ed or ed or something like that it's like a it's a it's a it's a holiday tradition i don't actually know much about it
但快乐 Ed 或 Eid。好吧，嗯，呃，宽扎节。嗯，我想这涵盖了一切。我要简短而甜蜜，只说圣诞快乐，明年见。圣诞快乐，新年快乐，明年我们有一个令人难以置信的节目。我们实际上已经录制好了。我不会剧透它，但它绝对，在我看来，是我们迄今为止做过的最高调的采访。这是一个绝对非凡的节目。我们不知道它什么时候会出来。日子会是。它实际上不是来自我们，
but happy ed or eid okay um uh kwanzaa um i think that covers everything i'm gonna go short and sweet and just say merry christmas and see you guys next year merry christmas happy new year and next year we have an unbelievable show. We actually already recorded it. I'm not going to spoil it, but it is definitely, in my opinion, the highest profile interview we've ever done up until now. It's an absolutely phenomenal show. We don't know when it's going to come out. The day is going to be. It's actually not coming from us,
所以我们不一定能控制日子。但它准备好了，实际上不是，嗯，它，它不是来自我们，所以，所以我们不一定能控制日子，但它准备好了，而且，呃，真的很期待它，我认为它绝对会让你大吃一惊。嗯，你有一个美好的一年，让我们，让我们明年再做一次。再见。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 根据知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以重新混合、改编作品，但你必须向帕特里克和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。
so we're not necessarily in control of the day. But it's ready to go, actually not um it's it's not coming from us so so we're not necessarily in control of the day but it's ready to go and uh really looking forward to it i think it's going to absolutely knock your socks off um you have an amazing year and let's let's do it again next year see ya the intro music is axo by binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以我们不一定能掌控这一天。但它已经准备就绪了，实际上不是……它不是来自我们，所以我们不一定能掌控这一天，但它已经准备就绪了。真的非常期待，我认为它绝对会让你大吃一惊。祝你度过美好的一年，让我们明年再见。再见。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播该作品，也可以进行重混和改编，但你必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。